To have understood the meaning of the fight we are fighting
for the reconquest of the territory
and for the real independence of Burkina Faso,
deux-mille-vingt-quatre will be 1 year during
which we will continue this fight,
we will
continue to break the chains of slavery,
to break the chains and therefore of neo-ism
that prevents us from knowing the desert.
During this year deux-mille-vingt-quatre,
we will continue our efforts to recapture the
territory and amplify the struggle.
That's why
on the La Défense side,
we will see the creation therefore
of the 1st combat that we have named
so the crown
special and rapid intervention system that will bring together the
various rapid intervention battalions,
1 group of forces
special and 1 specific grouping.
This is always in the sense
of the reorganization of our army,
of its rearticulation,
the relocation of the different forces
able to cope.
1 strategic equipment plan
and 1 plan to reorganize the different forces
was born in deux-mille-vingt-trois.
This will become a reality in deux-mille-vingt-quatre
by the arrival of new heavy means
of protection
and therefore increase the firepower
combatant units,
in addition to stealing.
You should know that deux-mille-vingt-quatre
will also be 1 year of challenges
because we are attached to
objectives in the field
and therefore the reconquest
and also therefore the return of the different pdi
in their locality
and their security
during the deux-mille-vingt-trois year.
As I was telling you,
many initiatives have been initiated
and deux-mille-vingt-quatre,
we should be able to deepen
and put
really implement everything we have started,
including the
Method for food self-sufficiency
and also the agro-pastoral offensive of the
Ministry of Agriculture
which has been launched recently.
The dry campaign is underway
in all these 2 initiatives so that we can
during the year deux-mille-vingt-quatre reach
if necessary,
approach food self-sufficiency.
This is a challenge for us
and so I invite the Burkinabe people
to appropriate its initiatives
and to be able to launch
wherever you are
so that the state can also accompany you
and that we can meet this challenge
in the demands of industrialization and also therefore
of everything that can
go in the direction of bringing 1 more
to all these valiant merchants who make
as best they can
to serve the
different localities of Burkina Faso.
Many initiatives will be taken in this direction.
Peace is already launched
which will allow us to have 1 certain number of plants,
but many initiatives are to come
during the deux-mille-vingt-quatre year.
During the year deux-mille-vingt-quatre,
we will again ask the Burkinabe people
to be able to appropriate the initiative
Commitment to community development,
This after analysis of the health situation.
As we said on 11/12,
we must be able to
to rebuild our cities and to be able to clean up.
It will therefore be
for the population to appropriate this initiative
and to be able to launch
in sanitation,
urbanization and
ensure that our living environments
are even more pleasant.
So that some of the icons we have known
cannot reappear during that year,
the fight we are fighting today is
also 1 fight of culture.
As you may have noticed,
by posing us 1 demonic of the problem,
we understood that colonization has uprooted us.
We have lost our culture,
our beautiful culture that teaches us peace,
solidarity,
Indonesia,
we have lost its values.
That's why
we want culture to occupy 1 place
important in our fight.
This is what led to today
make our national languages official
and also to create the community council
through this
bill
which has just been adopted in the assembly.
This should bring us back to our roots,
to our traditions,
to our cultures
to be able to make
re-emerge its values of
solidarity that we miss a lot,
its values of peace,
tolerance and belonging.
On the corruption side,
it must be said that the year deux-mille-vingt-trois
was 1 year
where this phenomenon has persisted.
For deux-mille-vingt-quatre,
we therefore intend to launch
the machine of the fight against corruption.
This is the place for me to invite
all these institutions and
structures that are therefore working in the fight against
corruption to redouble its efforts
so that,
forever,
we can banish
this phenomenon of our society.
Comrade,
we remain convinced of our trajectory,
of the lineage we have adopted.
There is no
better than this route we took
for our freedom,
for our sovereignty
and for Burkina to prosper.
We are convinced,
and with the Burkinabe people,
we are reassured
more than ever,
that the fight we are fighting is noble
for Burkina Faso,
for the E. S.
and for the whole of Africa.
We will wish you a very good year
deux-mille-vingt-quatre,
1 year full of health,
1 year of fighting spirit,
1 year during which therefore
all burkinabs
will be able to cultivate love between them,
1 year in which we wish to
that the Burkinabe can look like a girl
of the different things they have known
and therefore be able to look together towards the future,
1 year of college,
1 year in which
the hopes of all
so they will be fulfilled.
We will not be able to finish
without thanking
the Burkinabe people who understood the meaning of the struggle
and who fights day and night in the citizen's vigil
to protect this transition,
because, they say,
the enemy has not yet put away his hatchet.
Whether from the inside or from the outside,
is still active.
Thank you
to the Burkinabe people for this fight that we are waging
and thanks to all those who,
from near and far,
we think,
whether it is from the inside,
from the outside,
all over the world,
who supports Burkina Faso in this struggle.
Long live Burkina Faso!
May God protect Burkina Faso,
the fatherland or death,
we will win.